tis the season for gifts and if you're  an Xbox Live Gold member you'll get some  free games for Microsoft I'm Tony this  is a GameSpot news update and this is  your games with gold December lineup  first up the Xbox one titles Sleeping  Dogs definitive edition is the prettiest  version of United fronts Hong Kong crime  game and it'll be available throughout  December the beloved indie horror game  outlast is also coming and that will be  available from December 16th through  January 15th as for the 360 multicolored  platformer Outland will be available  from December 1st through the 15th it's  also getting smash hit racing game  burnout paradise from December 16th  through the 31st any of those sound good  to you and those are the games with gold  for December before they arrive you can  still grab November's games including  super dungeon Bros and Far Cry 3 Blood  Dragon and from all the latest from  Microsoft you're already in the right  place